toujours sérieux mais la guerre il faut
pas plaisanter elle raymond devos dans
le texte dans l'attitude et dans la
pensée interprété par cet adolescent de
bièvre âgés de 11 à 14 ans à la création
marguerite shane artiste
pluridisciplinaire invité par le
festival continue à transmettre le les
oeuvres de raymond devos parce que
c'était quelque chose qui lui tenait à
coeur et donc notamment pour les jeunes
générations
et de d'avoir un échange avec avec ces
jeunes là de pouvoir monter en quelques
séances un petit spectacle petite
performance autour de l'univers de
raymond devos
le travail sur le texte mais aussi sur
le mouvement
marguerite chahine a voulu jouer sur les
codes urbains du battle hip hop
les apprentis comédiens ont travaillé
lors de quatre sessions pendant la cour
de théâtre fait travailler en groupes
français comme le théâtre un peu
et du coup c'est un peu de la danse je
vous intéressant c'est l'occasion de
passer devant du monde et de bas a
répété une scène de théâtre
on enchaîne beaucoup d'émotion les
gestes la voix etc
je trouve ça super à raymond devos
continuera à planer sur cette soirée du
13 avril les jeunes laisseront leur
place à michael hirsh avec son spectacle
pourquoi pourquoi être comme tout le
monde
je veux dire il ya déjà plein de monde
comme tout le monde
[Musique]